>>> GOOD EVENING.
WE BEGIN TONIGHT WITH A
STUNNINGLY SIMPLE FACT.
THE FORMER PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES HAS JUST LOUDLY
AND PROUDLY CONFESSED TO THE
VERY THING THE HOUSE SELECT
COMMITTEE IS HARD AT WORK TRYING
TO PROVE.
HE HAS ALSO JUST DANGLED PARDONS
IN FRONT OF THE PEOPLE WHO
ATTACKED THE CAPITOL AND LEVELED
STRALED THREATS, HINTING AT
POTENTIAL MOB VIOLENCE AT THOSE
WHO WOULD INVESTIGATE OR
PROSECUTE HIM.
YET, THAT FACT THAT HE DID ALL
THAT IN JUST A SINGLE WEEKEND
SHOCKING AS IT IS, ALSO COMES
WITH THE DEPRESSINGLY FAMILIAR
COROLLARY.
IT HAS ALWAYS BEEN THIS WAY.
HE HALTZ ALWAYS SAID THE QUIET
PART OUT LOUD, WHETHER AFTER THE
FACT OR BEFORE OR BOTH.
HE IS CONSCIOUSLY OR NOT A
SERIOUS CONFESSOR.
AND YESTERDAY, THE STATEMENT HE
DID IT AGAIN.
THE ONCE AND PERHAPS FUTURE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
SAID THIS ABOUT FORMER-VICE
PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE.
QUOTE, HE COULD HAVE OVERTURNED
THE ELECTION.
NOW, THAT'S AS CLEAR A STATEMENT
AS YOU CAN FIND OF HIS INTENT TO
REMAIN IN OFFICE BY NULLIFYING
THE RESULTS OF A FREE AND FAIR
ELECTION.
HE IS EVEN USING THE LANGUAGE
OVERTURN THE ELECTION, WHICH IS
THE VERY THING THE JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE IS TRYING TO PROVE.
NOW, THAT STATEMENT, THAT'S WHAT
IT IS CALLED, ESSENTIALLY
ADMITTING HE ATTEMPTED TO STAGE
A COUP FOLLOWED REMARKS IN TEXAS
WHERE HE SAID THIS ABOUT MEMBERS
OF THE VIOLENT MOB WHO TOOK PART
IN THAT VERY ATTEMPT, NOW IN
JAIL AWAITING TRIAL CHARGED WITH
DESTROYING PROPERTY, ASSAULTING
POLICE OFFICERS, WEAPONS
POSSESSION, AND TO OVERTHROW,
PUT OUT, OR DESTROY BY FORCE THE
GOVERNMENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
>> IF I RUN AND IF I WIN, WE
WILL TREAT THOSE PEOPLE FROM
JANUARY 6th FAIRLY.
WE WILL TREAT THEM FAIRLY.
AND IF IT REQUIRES PARDONS, WE
WILL GIVE THEM PARDONS BECAUSE
THEY ARE BEING TREATED SO
UNFAIRLY.
>> SO UNFAIRLY, HE SAID.
THAT IS THE FORMER PRESIDENT
DANGLING PARDONS IN FRONT OF
ALLEGED FELONS, SOME OF WHOM
MIGHT BE CALLED ON ONE DAY TO
TESTIFY AGAINST HIM.
YET AGAIN, SHOULDN'T BE THAT
SURPRISING.
HE HAS DONE IT OPENLY BEFORE,
AND PAID NO PRICE FOR IT.
BACK IN 2018 WHEN HE REFUSED TO
RULE OUT PARDONING HIS CORRUPT
FORMER CAMPAIGN ADVISER PAUL
MANAFORT.
>> THINK THE WHOLE MANAFORT
TRIAL IS VERY SAD.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT'S GOING ON
THERE, I THINK IT'S A VERY SAD
DAY FOR OUR COUNTRY.
HE WORKED FOR ME FOR A VERY
SHORT PERIOD OF TIME BUT YOU
KNOW WHAT?
HE HAPPENS TO BE A VERY GOOD
PUNISH.
AND I THINK IT'S VERY SAD WHAT
THEY HAVE DONE TO PAUL MANAFORT.
>> HE WOULD OF COURSE GO ON TO
PARDON PAUL MANAFORT AND ROGER
STONE, NEITHER OF WHOM IN HIS
WORDS EVER FLIPPED ON HIM.
SO, WHAT HE SAW ON SATURDAY
SHOULDN'T BE SURPRISING.
THE BEHAVIOR AND INTENT WERE OUT
IN THE OPEN YEARS BEFORE.
AS WAS GOING BACK TO HIS FIRST
CAMPAIGN, HIS INTENTION TO LET A
FOREIGN POWER HACK AMERICAN
COMPUTERS AND TAMPER WITH
AMERICAN DEMOCRACY.
>> RUSSIA, IF YOU ARE LISTENING,
I HOPE YOU ARE ABLE TO FIND THE
30,000 E-MAILS THAT ARE MISSING.
I THINK YOU WILL PROBABLY BE
REWARDED MIGHTILY BY OUR PRESS.
>> WELL FIVE HOURS LATER,
ACCORDING TO THE MUELLER REPORT,
THE RUSSIAN HACKING BEGAN.
HIS SUBSEQUENT EXPLANATION TO
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL'S TEAM WAS
THAT IT WAS A JOKE, QUOTE, AS
WAS APPARENT TO ANY OBJECTIVE
OBSERVER.
NOW, YOU WOULD THINK THIS WAS
PERHAPS HIS FIRST LESSON IN HOW
EASY IT WOULD BE FOR HIM TO SAY
THE QUIET PART OUT LOUD, AND NOT
FACE ANY CONSEQUENCES.
EXCEPT, IN TRUTH, IT WASN'T.
SIX MONTHS EARLIER, IN WHAT WAS
FOR HIM AT LEAST A SURPRISINGLY
SELF-AWARE AND MAYBE META
OBSERVATION, HE SAID THIS.
>> I COULD STAND IN THE MIDDLE
OF FIFTH AVENUE, AND SHOOT
SOMEBODY AND I WOULDN'T LOSE ANY
VOTERS.
OKAY?
>> NOW, IN THIS CASE, THANK
GOODNESS, HE WAS SPEAKING
FIGURATIVELY, WHICH OF COURSE
LATER GAVE RISE TO HIS HANDLERS
AND ENABLERS TELLING US OH WE
SHOULD TAKE -- WE SHOULD TAKE
THE MAN SERIOUSLY, NOT
LITERALLY.
EXCEPT AS IT WOULD HAPPEN, THE
BEST WAY TO PREDICT WHAT HE
WOULD DO OR HOW HE FELT ABOUT
SOMETHING OR EXPLAIN IT AFTER
THE FACT WOULD BE TO TAKE WHAT
HE SAID LITERALLY.
WANT TO KNOW IF HE HAD A SOFT
SPOT FOR WHITE NATIONALISTS?
TAKE HIM LITERALLY.
>> YOU HAD SOME VERY BAD PEOPLE
IN THAT GROUP.
BUT YOU ALSO HAD PEOPLE THAT
WERE VERY FINE PEOPLE ON BOTH
SIDES.
>> NOW, TO REMIND YOU, THIS WAS
ONE OF THE TWO SIDES HE WAS
TALKING ABOUT.
WHITE NATIONALISTS CHANTING JEWS
WILL NOT REPLACE US AND THE NAZI
SLOGAN BOD BLOOD AND SOIL.
AND YOU DIDN'T NEED TO READ UPON
BETWEEN THE LINES TO SEE WHERE
HIS SYMPATHIES LAY, JUST NEEDED
TO TAKE HIS WORDS AT FACE VALUE.
AND IF THERE WERE ANY DOUBT AT
THE TIME ABOUT HIS AFFINITY FOR
THUGS, YOU COULD TAKE WHAT HE
SAID IN MARCH OF 2019 AT FACE
VALUE.
WHEN HE BOASTED ABOUT THE BIKERS
WHO SUPPORTED HIM SAYING, QUOTE,
I HAVE THE TOUGH PEOPLE BUT THEY
DON'T PLAY IT TOUGH UNTIL THEY
GO TO A CERTAIN POINT, AND THEN
IT WOULD BE VERY BAD, VERY BAD.
NOBODY TOOK THAT SERIOUSLY
ENOUGH AT THE TIME.
NOR, DID MANY TAKE THESE REMARKS
IN FRONT OF TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DEBATE VIEWERS SERIOUSLY ENOUGH,
OR SEE THEM AS THE FORESHADOWING
THEY WERE OF JANUARY 6th.
>> PROUD BOYS, STAND BACK AND
STAND BY.
>> AGAIN, THERE THEY ARE.
WORDS THAT THE FORMER
PRESIDENT'S ENABLERS DID NOT
TAKE EITHER SERIOUSLY OR
LITERALLY, EVEN THOUGH THE PROUD
BOYS CERTAINLY SEEMED TO AND
AGAIN, THEY, TOO, WERE PART OF A
PATTERN DATING BACK TO
THEN-CANDIDATE TRUMP REFUSING TO
DENOUNCE FORMER KKK LEADER DAVID
DUKE WHEN PRESSED REPEATEDLY ON
IT BY CNN JAKE TAPPER.
HE SUBSEQUENTLY BLAMED IT ON A
BAD EARPIECE BUT WOULD
FORESHADOW HIS RELUCTANCE TO
CONDEMN HATERS IN
CHARLOTTESVILLE.
THEN OF COURSE, WENT ON TO
BECOME ONE OF HIS STAUNCH
SUPPORTERS AND ENABLERS.
THAT WAS SIX -- NEARLY SIX YEARS
AGO.
COUNTLESS INDICTMENTS OF
ASSOCIATES AGO, TWO IMPEACHMENTS
AND ONE INSURRECTION AGO, AND SO
VERY MUCH OF IT WAS OPENLY
TELEGRAPHED OR OPENLY ADMITTED
TO AFTER THE FACT.
AND EVEN NOW, EVEN SOMEONE WHO
VOTED TO CONVICT HIM IN HIS
SECOND IMPEACHMENT AND WHO
CONDEMNS HIS PLEDGE TO PARDON
JANUARY 6th CRIMINALS, STILL
CANNOT COMPLETELY RULE OUT
SUPPORTING HIM IN 2024.
>> WELL, WE'RE A LONG WAYS FROM
2024 BUT LET ME SAY THIS.
I DO NOT THINK THE PRESIDENT
SHOULD HAVE MADE -- PRESIDENT
TRUMP SHOULD HAVE MADE THAT
PLEDGE TO DO  BURDENS PRLDS.
WE SHOULD LET THE JUDICIAL
PROCESS PROCEED.
IT WAS A DARK DAY IN OUR
HISTORY.
>> IT WAS, AND YOU VOTED TO
CONVICT PRESIDENT TRUMP AS WELL.
WHY CAN'T YOU RULE OUT
SUPPORTING HIM IN 2024?
>> WELL CERTAINLY, IT'S NOT
LIKELY, GIVEN THE MANY OTHER
QUALIFIED CANDIDATES THAT WE
HAVE THAT HAVE EXPRESSED
INTEREST IN RUNNING SO IT'S VERY
UNLIKELY.
>> SO, SHE VOTED TO CONVICT HIM
IN PROCEEDINGS WHERE A
CONVICTION WOULD HAVE BARRED HIM
FROM EVER HOLDING OFFICE, AGAIN.
WHICH SHE WAS COMFORTABLE WITH
WHEN SHE VOTED TO CONVICT HIM.
YET SOMEHOW, NOW, SHE CAN'T
SIMPLY SAY OUT LOUD WHAT SHE
SAID WITH HER VOTE JUST A YEAR
AGO.
A YEAR, THAT HARD HI SAW THE
FORMER PRESIDENT MELLOW.
JUST THE OPPOSITE.
NOW, HER REMARKS CAME JUST A DAY
AFTER HE OPENLY TRIED TO MAKE
MARTYRS AND HEROES OUT OF THE
MOB THAT TERRORIZED HER OWN
WORKPLACE, AND THREATENED TO
HANG THE MAN PRESIDING OVER IT.
AND IT'S NOT LIKE THAT THREAT IS
RECEDING.
HERE IS WHAT THE MAN SHE STILL
MIGHT SUPPORT ALSO SAID ON
SATURDAY ABOUT THE PUBLIC
SERVANTS, SWOV SWORN OFFICERS OF
THE COURT, WHO ARE INVESTIGATING
HIM.
>> IT REALLY IS PROSECUTORIAL
MISCONDUCT AT THE HIGHEST LEVEL.
THESE PROSECUTORS ARE VICIOUS,
HORRIBLE PEOPLE.
THEY'RE RACISTS, AND THEY'RE
VERY SICK.
THEY'RE MENTALLY SICK.
IF THESE RADICAL, VICIOUS,
RACIST PROSECUTORS DO ANYTHING
WRONG OR ILLEGAL, I HOPE WE ARE
GOING TO HAVE, IN THIS COUNTRY,
THE BIGGEST PROTEST WE HAVE EVER
HAD IN WASHINGTON, D.C., IN NEW
YORK, IN ATLANTA, AND ELSEWHERE
BECAUSE OUR COUNTRY AND OUR
ELECTIONS ARE CORRUPT.
>> SO, JUST TAKE A STEP BACK AND
WHEN YOU HEAR HIM SAY THAT AT
THE END.
THAT IS A FORMER PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES JUST IN A
SENTENCE SAYING OUR COUNTRY AND
OUR ELECTIONS ARE CORRUPT.
THE FORMER PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES IS SAYING OUR
COUNTRY IS CORRUPT.
OUR ELECTIONS ARE CORRUPT.
NOBODY BLINKS AN EYE.
I MEAN, CAN YOU IMAGINE FOR A
MOMENT, IF ANY OTHER PRESIDENT
OR FORMER PRESIDENT SAID THOSE
WORDS IN PREVIOUS YEARS?
THERE WOULD BE OUTRAGE.
THE PRESIDENT'S WORDS,
ENCOURAGING MOBS TO RALLY
AGAINST PUBLIC SERVANTS PROMPTED
ATLANTA AREA DISTRICT ATTORNEY
FANNY WILLIS TO ASK THE FBI FOR
HELP IN PROVIDING SECURITY FOR
BUILDINGS AND STAFF FOR SECURITY
ASSISTANCE.
SHE IS INVESTIGATING THE FORMER
PRESIDENT'S EFFORT TO OVERTURN
RESULTS IN GEORGIA.
SHE IS DOING HER JOB.
WHETHER IT COM